abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
Hoş geldiniz Hoş buldum Şu anda beni
seyreden şu anda burada bulunan oturan
ya da başka bir zaman diliminde mavi
ekranda seyredecek olan da sen şu anda
beni seyreden desen ve benim Z hitap
ederken sizi gözlemlerken
sana bakan
ben de sen ne demek istiyorum
şimdi
baktığımızda
Bae evrende çok değerli olan bilimsel
anlamda ispatlanmış Kuantum fiziğine bir
yolculuk var Bilim insanlarından iki
değerli bilim insanı Einstein ve
Tesla'nın çok kıymetli iki sözü var
evrenin gizemini anlamak istiyorsanız
enerji frekans ve titreşim cinsinden
düşünün der Tesla şu anda iyi başka şey
söyler önyargıları parçalamak atomu
parçalamaktan zordur
Neden bunu söylüyorum biraz evvel örnek
verdiğim
bensem sende bensem Peki Biz kimiz çok
önemli bir sorunu cevabı bir o kadar hem
karışık hem çok basit
cevabını çok rahatlıkla bulabileceğimiz
alan ise kuantum fiziğinde o zor efekt
yani gözlemcinin etkisi altında yer
alıyor Bu ne anlama geliyor sonsuz
olasılıklar da kuantum alanında sizin
yani gözlemcinin Yani şu anda sizin
bakmış olduğu açıdan baktığımızda veya
benim açımdan baktığımızda bakmış
olduğunuz nesneyi objeyi etkileyen in
Sizler olduğunu anladığınız a1in
seviyenizde muazzam bir değişim ve
dönüşüm oluyor bu dersimiz Şu anda
kuantum fiziği değil ben çok basit
anlamda şu kartınıza ne anlama
geleceğini paylaşmak istiyorum
örnek olarak diyelim ki E senin hayat
hikayesi var sizin ve Hadi kendiniz var
hayatımızı bir film gibi düşündüğümüzde
hayatımızın yönetmeni
bizi senaristi de biziz
iyi oyuncusu da biziz ama en önemlisi en
önemlisi onaylayan yargılayan kabul
veren değer gören kişi olan seyirci de
yine biziz Yani eğer ben hayatımda hem
yönetmen hem Senarist hem oyuncu aynı
zamanda gözlemleyen kişiyi Sem burada
bütün istemiş olduğum gerçekliği
yaratırken konumuz olan ribor da her
nefesimizde her anımızda yeni bir
gerçekliği yeni bir oluşa bu yandı ımızı
ve bunu buradan çıktığımızda hepimizin
bilinç seviyesinde bir farklılık
olacağına göre bunu bilinçli ya da
bilinçsiz şekilde yapacağımız ın ayrı mı
bize kalmış
bununla beraber baktığımızda beyin beyin
altı çalışmalar bilinçaltı beynin
çalışmaları zeka Yapay Zeka Bunlar benim
Hem bireysel anlamda hem tutkum hem
hobim ve aynı bu mesleğim üniversite
hayatıma dilbilim alanında başladıktan
sonraki yolculuğumda hayat beni beyinle
ilgili dokunduğum hissettiğim gördüğüm
çalıştığım Muazzam bambaşka teknolojide
içinde olmuş olduğu Kurbağalara kadar
getirdi aslında bir teknoloji Kadınıyım
girişimci mi aynı zamanda Medikal
teknolojilerde yaklaşık 30 yıldan beri
çalışırken hayatın bana getirmiş olduğu
enteresan şeyleri paylaşacağım sizlerle
konu bu Das alte sen geri Tümer'in neler
yaptığını Nasıl yeniden doğdu değil her
oluşumunda nereden beslendiği ve bunları
gerçekleştirirken çok başarılı olurken
Hem bu da özel hayatımda iş hayatında
bereketin de boğulduğunda hepsini
yapılabileceği Mümkünse Bunları sadece
ruhsal değil zihinsel değil bedensel Gül
hepsinin birbirine bütün bütüncül
olduğunu holistik olduğunu ve çok
anlamlı olduğunu paylaşmak istiyorum bu
vücuduma İslam Üniversitesi'nde İngiliz
dili edebiyatı ve dilbilim okurken
beynin bugün özellikle kognitif bilimsel
alanlarda yapay zekaya baz alan kısmında
30 yıl önce Bundan iyi timleri almış
olduğum zaman onun o dönem içerisinde
Bugün ne kadar anlamlı olduğunu farkında
bile değilim yolculuk devam etti Daha
sonra Amerika'ya gittim Amerika da
w150d üniversitede master eğitimi
aldıktan sonra Türkiye döndüm ve tekrar
Amerika gittiğim zaman da Amerikalı bir
Medikal teknoloji firmasında dünya
çapında Büyük bir firmada sağlık
alanında çalışmalara başladım hayvan
laboratuvarları kadavralar beyni
çalıştığımız bedeni çalıştığımız
eğitimler aldığımız dünya çapında
geçerli sertifika ile ülkeye döndükten
sonra Türkiye'de ve dünyada binden fazla
ameliyata yeşil alana scruff girerek
teknolojilerin hekimlere cerrahları
öğretilmesine vesile oldum bir bu
anlattığım gibi Zihni sadece bilişsel
değil bununla beraber di dokunarak da
fiziki ortamda da ne anlama gelmiş
olduğunu görme şansım olabildi ve
bakkallara girdikçe beynin gizemli
yolculuğunda Muazzam keşiflerde bulundum
Burada şu anlatacaklarım işe yardım ana
kadar hangi kariyer basamaklarından
gelişmeler yaptım ve selden ziyade çok
bambaşka bir kesitten bahsetmek
istiyorum size Örnek olsun diye bu çok
kıymetli olduğunu düşünüyorum çünkü
burada gerçekten potansiyelimizi
Kullanmadığımız ı kullanmak istediğimiz
zaman ise bazı engellerimiz ne olduğunu
hepimiz hiç farkında olmadan biraz evvel
söylediğim gözlemci etkisiyle kendi
kendimizi sabote ettiğimizi görüyoruz
akabinde kariyerime devam ederken yine
başka Bulut sırası firmada Hollandalı
firmasında da özellikle manyetik
rezonansın da içinde bulunmuş oldu
nükleer tıp ultrasona Yollarında
bulunmuş olduğu bir da artık sadece
beyine dokunan kognitif bilen değil aynı
zamanda bütün görüntüleri görebilen
kıyasla ya bilen bir hale gelebildiğini
için bu benim için Muazzam yolculuk oldu
ama bu da hayatımıza giderken
baktığımızda daha sonra almış olduğum
yöresel sürebilir eğitimleri ile bütün
oradaki bütün gözlemlediğimiz
topladığımız bilinçaltına atmış
olduğumuz kayıtlarımızla beraber bizi
sabote eden engelleyen konularda görme
idrak etme şansım oldu ve beyindeki bu
yolculuk Kale hayatıma devam ederken de
nelerle karşılaştım bilincimiz var
bilinçaltımız var aynı buzdağının
altında görünmeyen kısmının görünenden
çok derin ve daha büyük olduğu gibi o
dönemlerde bulunduğu firmada direkt
ördüm genel müdür değildim ve bana şunu
söylüyorlardı
bilinçaltımdaki korku ve kaygıların
vardı ve dış ses vardı bu mühendis
değilsin erkek değilsin 50 yaşın
üzerinde değilsin anda sakson değilsin
Değilsin değilsin yani genel müdür
olmayı bana hayal bile etme diyorlardı
Fakat benim içimdeki ses hayır Türk'üm
Müslümanım kadınım mühendisliği ilim
elli yaşında değilim 30'lu yaşlar dayım
Ben gidin genelde olabilirim ama başka
bir korkum vardı dış sesin söylemiş
oldukları görmezden gelirken
bilinçaltında başka bir korkum var dış
Çünkü neokorteks yen benim bilinçli
kısımdan ettin kızım yaparım derken
bilinçaltım
yapamazsın neden kendi sabote ettiğim
çekirdek inancı bize yetersizsin finansı
çok iyi bilmiyorsun finansı çok iyi
bilmediğin zamanda ya şirketi batırsan
diye iç korkumla Beraber Yüzleşme
yediğimden şu seçim yapabilirdim hayat
hikayem de kurban bölümü seçerek dış
sesin söylemiş oldu ya bu kısımlar
kısmındaki oradaki chakless uzaya
bilirdi onu bahane eden ben süperim ama
bunlardan dolayı kadınım mühendis
değilim gibi ajite eden kendimi haklı
çıkartan toplum içerisinde beni haklı
bulacak
yargılara sahip ve sahiplenebilirim onun
yerine onu seçmedim korkunla yüzleşmeyi
Korkumdan büyük olmayı seçtim konforma
çıkmak içinde birçok eğitim aldım Bu
arada oradan iyi keşfettim yetersizlik
hissi mlke
kavuşmayı buluşmayı idrak etmeyi Yani
evet yeter sizin bu konu bilmiyorum
mükemmel olmaktan kontrollü olmaktan
çıkıp bilmediğim idrak ettiğim de
korkumla yüzleştiğim de bu Herhangi bir
şey olabilir yetersizlik değersizlik
Sevgi Sizi yalnız kalma korkusu vesaire
ve servis sadece korkularımızla
bilinçaltındaki kucakladığı mı zaman
orada bir kuantum sıçraması oluyor Baban
da vesile oldu ve o yabancı firma da beş
sene sonra Olabilecek olan potansiyel
genel müdür olma olasılığı benim
yetersizlik He simle kabullenme Yüzleşme
Onunla beraber Çağrı bulma ile
sonuçlandı ne yaptın bir seviyesi
bilinçaltında artık yetersiz isimle bir
kere bir helalleştik bununla beraber de
benim her şeyi bilmek zorunda
olmadığımı idrak etmez Omuzlarından
Muazzam you kaldırdı en iyi finansçılar
da en iyi insan kaynakları teknolojileri
ya tedavi çalışabilirim ama sonuç
itibariyle benden beklenen orkestra şefi
olmamdı benim bilim seviyemde i
suçlamayla benim çok uzun süre daha
sonra olmam gereken genel müdür
pozisyonundaki atanmam sadece bir hafta
içerisinde oldu bu net bir zihinsel
kuantum sıçrama Bunu neden sizlerle
paylaşıyorum hayatınızda şu anda buradan
çıkarken Sen çok rica ve her birinize
neyi bahane ediyorsunuz Ne istiyorsunuz
neyi bahane ediyorsunuz bunun
gerçekleşmesi konusunda kendine çok
dürüst olup çok net bahaneleriniz e
gözlemci etkinizi aldanmadan yüzleşip
Onunla beraber onun kurban durumdan
çıkıp hayatınızın oskarlık Bir Film mi
vasat bir film mi olacağını kararı veren
Dış Dünya asla değil Tamamen sizin
kendinize vereceğiniz bir karar zaman
geçtiği zaman bu keşifler beni çok
heyecanlandırdı Genel Müdür oldum
başarılar geldi Hadi burada bir çok
Hikayemiz daha var onları hızlı
geçiyorum vaktinizi gitti olduğu için
daha sonra başarılı bir iş Kadınıyım
teknolojide liderim defalarca ödülleri
alıyorum ama Konfor alanındayım ve
kendimi tekrarlamaya başladı mı görünüm
burada başarısızlıklar yok mu elbetteki
var buz dağında olduğu gibi başarıyı
görüyorsunuz ama arka tarafında olan
kayıpları fedakârlıkları
de görmesek de biz rafine üstteki olan
kısmına bakıyoruz sadece hızlı
gittiğiniz zaman bir toplantıda
endüstri40 toplantısına bir şey idrak
ettiğim zaman Deliler genel müdür
pozisyonları kalmıyor problemler
gelebiliyor bir şey genel değil
özelliğine dedi ki bir şekilde
öğrenmeniz gerekiyor diye Almış
olduğumuz bir ve seminer vardı beni çok
etkiledi Ve şuna karar verdim 50 yaşında
Muazzam başarılı bir şeyi olabilirsiniz
insan kaynakları Finans hangi işi
yaparsanız yapın aynı şeyleri
tekrarlayıp bir yere bak gelmeniz başı
olur Mümkün değil bu yüzden çok sevmiş
olduğum alan da tutkum oldu alan Yapay
Zeka teknolojilerinde eğitim Almaya
karar verdim yolculuk yapay zeka ile
beraber Amerika'ya kadar evrildi
Harvard'da Yapay Zeka eğitim almadan
önce uçakta okuduğum bir kitap çok
etkiledi beni yordu ki mikroorganizmalar
vardı ama daha sonra insanoğlu geldi Ey
insanoğlu karbon bazlı senin bu sonu
bazlığı
robotlardan daha iyi olduğunu nereden
biliyorsun diye Bu da farklı bir açıldı
Yani biz kendinizi evrimleşmiş en iyi
hale gelmesine derken öyle olmadığını
görüyoruz Amerika'da sınıf arkadaşım
Japon Japon bir kadın yüzü Berrin'in San
francisco'dan gelen radyolog bir hanım
1. sınıf arkadaşım Harput'ta burada ne
yapıyorsun diye sorduğumda kadın şunu
söyledi meslek elden gidiyor ne
yapacağımı öğrenmeye geldim bu niye
önemli dünya eriyor havadaki bizim Almış
olduğumuz derslerden ilk hocamız çok
güzel espirili konuşması vardı mesleğini
Baba annene söylüyorsun anlıyorsa sorry
For You Sen için üzgünüm Yani eskiden
babaannem Tıpkı biliyordu mühendisliği
biliyordu yeni bölümler var Tıp
mühendisliği gibi teknolojisağlık ciddi
alanda Eylül'e biliyor ömrümüz 100
yaşına kadar uzuyor kök hücre lerimizden
yapılan yedek parça organlarımız ve
ayrıca bir dünyada öyle bir hale
geliyoruz ki kariyer Bir değil iki değil
üçüncüsü yaşamaya gelebiliyor daha sonra
yine Harvard'da çalışırken bir tezim
vardı benim çok ilgimi çeken benim
dediğim gibi bunu keşfettiğim zaman
muazzam bir keyif almıştım hepinizin
bildiği ayku İyi ki yani matematiksel
zeka ile beraber duygusal zekayı
biliyoruz bilmediğimiz kullanmadım iki
zeka türlü hava Peki fiziksel zeka Ben
zamanda eski you spiral ıntelligence
yani ruhsal zeka Yapay Zeka
teknolojileri dersindeyiz ve ben bu da
bizim hazırlarken şunu şunu idrak ettim
Fark ettim hocam da paylaştım
makinalar Yapay Zeka teknoloji ve
robotlar Neyi replase ediyor neyin
yerine alabiliyor çok kolaylıkla aykunu
ve Pick ün yani fiziksel ve matematiksel
algoritmalarla bunu yapabilmesi çok
kolayken iyi kuv bu gibi ruhsal ve
duygusal zekayı halen daha reflesi etme
şansları Günümüzde çok zor nedir bunlar
Vicdan Merhamet gibi sevgi ve bununla
beraber bütüncül görebilmek ve empati
kurabilmek kısmı henüz makinalarda
mümkün değil nerede mümkün ve kim de
mümkün Burada ise erkek ve kadın ayrımı
yapmıyorum dişi ve Eril enerji den
bahsediyorum Çünkü kadının değil dişi
enerjinin güçlü olduğu alanlar İyi ki ve
eski hükümlü bazı kadınlarda dişi değil
Eğil Eğer daha fazla olabilir acillerde
tam tersi olabiliyor O yüzden dişi
enerjinin teknoloji ile beraber ruhsal
ve duygusal zeka ile Yeni teknoloji
dünyasında muazzam bir uyanışa vesile
olduğunu görüyorum ve şunu söylüyorum
dişi enerji artık günümüzde çağımızda
oyuncu olmaktan çıkıp oyunu kuram haline
gelmeye başladı görebiliyoruz son ve
yapay zeka eğitimlerinden sonra çok
merak ettim nesnelerin interneti kısmı
vardır ve bununla beraber de Kolombiya
Üniversitesi'nde eğitimleri aldım ayoti
kısmında ve bununla ilgili çalışmalardan
sonra
Amerika'ya bir konu tarifi olmam
gerekiyor gitmem gerek içimdeki bir ses
gitmek istemiyorum ama en sonunda almış
olduğum bu eğitimlerle beraber
Amerika'dan döndüğümde uçaktan indiğimde
linkinden bir mesaj geldi İngiltere
manchester'da sizinle beraber çalışmak
istiyoruz advisory Board member ya
danışma kurulunda olabilirmisiniz ne
anlama geliyor derken iş defa
bilinçaltında korku ve kaygıları mı
kaldırdım Yeniden doğdum yıllarımı
kurumsala verirken bir anda yurt dışında
keşfedildi biliyorsam Çünkü zihinsel
bariyerleri beni engellediğini görmüş
olduğunuz zaman bir anda bu gelen
manchester'da sadece ayda Sekiz saatlik
gidebileceğim telekonferansla
katılacağım çeyrekte bir gideceğim
toplantılarla
yeni bir baş çok sıcak gelebileceğini
gördüğüme nereden beni bulduğumda
sorduğum zaman çok şaşırmıştım Yapay
Zeka teknoloji sağlık ve kadın diye
karşımıza grobel araştırmada Siz
geldiğiniz dedikleri zaman hem Onur
duydum hem de aslında bir yerlerde
güvensiz alanımda güvenli bir şekilde
kendime motive eden bir alan görebilmeyi
burada vesile oldu ve sonunda Amerika'da
ve Türkiye'de yapay zeka ve giyilebilir
teknolojiler iki tane start-up kurdum ve
tekrar kurumsaldan sonra birinci kalori
bitip ikinci kariyerimi yeniden doğarak
teknoloji kadını oldum ve yapay zeka
teknoloji Derneği'ni kurup kedi
kurduktan sonra da işlerime yönetim
kurullarında devam ediyorum Aynı zamanda
ve kendi Start haplarında ilerliyorum
peki biraz evvel anlattığımız bilişsel
anlamda beyne dokunduğumuz hissettiğimiz
ameliyatlara girdiğimiz hem bilinç
bilinçaltı beyni görüntülemesi ne kadar
holistik her açıdan gördüğümüz zaman
bunun yine O da ne anlama geldiğini Neyi
Korkut nereden Korktuğumuzda baktığımız
zaman hepsi bugün çok tartışılan son bu
sene özellikle İçinde bulunduğumuz
anlamda gelecek bizim Yapay Zeka
teknoloji Derneğimize yapılan anketler
diken büyük sorup robotlar yerimizi
alacaklarmış gibi kaygılarımız var ve
metaforas geliyor yani artırılmış
gerçeklik Eğer yarın veya yapay zekanın
blok şeyinden hepsini Entegre olmuş
olduğu meteoroloj bambaşka bir dünyayı
evlenirken biz bu dünyada nerede var
oluyoruz bizi bu korkutmalı mı Yoksa
koklamalı burada çok net bir şekilde
biraz evvel bahsettiğim gözlemci
etkisini kuantum Alırım da idrak
ederseniz İnşallah edersiniz hepiniz
buradan bilgiyi aldığınızda bunu bir
şekilde bilgi anlamlı hale getirmek
senemizde evrene baktığımızda beyin
hücresi ile evreninde neamh ızla çift
Ben yarın Gözümüz ile evrendeki bütün
olguların makrokozmoz lo mikrokozmos
aynı olduğu bir yerde sol tarafa bakalım
kadının bakmış oldu arttırmış gerçekte
neye bakarsa baksın
gözlemci etkisinin inandığı odaklandığı
kısımda onun parça veya dalga boyunda
hangi olasılıkları Evliliğine karar
veriyor diyebiliriz Bu ne anlama geliyor
bu günden itibaren kendi gözlemci
etkinizi kullanarak bunu hayırlı bir
şekilde istekleriniz doğrultusunda kendi
Hayat hikayenize en iyi şekilde
edilmesine birisiyle olun diyorum
içinizdeki gözlemciye selam olsun
Hoşçakalın Esen kalıp